pay somebody to set up a server with this on it on fiverr or freelancer.com right like even if
it's a couple hundred bucks like hit up hit up a developer that works with this software stack and
just says hey uh can you just like put this on the server and set it up and then you've got it set
up all right hackers i'm looking at my inbox right now for hacker one and i'm smiling ear to ear
because i got paid out a crit and it came from that last ctbb hack along that we did live in the
discord with a couple hundred of you guys present when i had to cut the stream and go report a
vulnerability live that resulted in a 7k crit from adobe guys i'm so pleased the adobe team also added
a 650 bonus to that report because uh i used the ctbb partnership code okay so i want to remind you
guys that adobe is offering a 10 increase in bounties to you guys the critical linking listeners
because you guys rock okay and that uh is targeting adobe stock and lightroom web
adobe stock and lightroom web and it is a 10 bonus for valid ai vulnerabilities mapped to owasp top 10 for
llms okay um so definitely go target those two products look at the ai features and report some awesome
bugs and you'll get that 10 bonus we'll put the the uh information down in the description the code is
ctbb063026 that's june 30th 2026 because that's when the promotion ends okay go tear them up guys
they're a really good program they're paying some great bounties and they're offering some special
love to you guys the ctbb listeners all right let's go back to the show all right so packers before we
hop into the episode today uh we've got the this week in bug bounty segment just took some rapid fire
news for you the only item on our list actually is very relevant to the episode and it is the open
source security testing guide uh by yes we hack okay um so we'll go ahead and link that down in the
description but we're going to spend a lot of time this episode talking about uh source code review and
that sort of thing and this while this guide is focused specifically on open source there are a lot
of really applicable techniques here um to any sort of source code review right um a lot of the tools
you need to know a lot of the terms you need to understand so give this a glance if you're getting
into that space um there's also another really big added benefit to these write-ups like these nowadays
which is you can feed these into your your ai hey say hey check this out write up a nice little skill
for this based off of this article and others um one of the ones that i thought was really nice in this
uh example was um mentioning that you can define uh bookmarks throughout the different pieces of code
uh that makes it easier for you to jump around into different pieces and follow your own code flows
inside of vs code love that so check out this article it'll be in the description
all right let's hop to the show all right hackers today i am attempting something quite
ambitious which is i'm going to try to give you guys um some cross between a meta analysis
and a recipe and just random thoughts thrown together on source code review um the idea originally
for this episode was like can i find a way to grab a bunch of different sources on source code review
analyze what kind of patterns we see across all of them and kind of put those into one episode so we did
that and then i kind of added a little bit of my thoughts here and there we asked a couple experts in
the industry got their thoughts pulled all that in um and that is what this episode turned into so i've
spent the past three hours reading through this document trying to tweak it trying to get it to the
spot where it needs to be um and hopefully and try to abstract some of the stuff as much as i can and
hopefully you guys will be able to get some uh good comprehensive coverage on the topic of source code
analysis okay um i think this is a really applicable topic right now because ai is is augmenting the space a lot
and while i will give you some tips on how to use ai for source code analysis today most of this is going
to be focused on the good old here's how you do source code analysis um source code review uh and you
can then take those and collaborate with claude or your ai of choice to to sort of superpower it okay so
um first let's let's go ahead and and jump right into it um the first thing that i want to challenge
you with if you're going to do source code review is what is your goal for the source code review looking
at um a couple of the main purposes for source code will reveal a couple things one for example if you
look at acid node or the sl cyber team um they are often just looking for pre-authority right that's also
the kind of thing you see in pone to own right if you know that you are just looking for pre-auth rce
you know you have to start from an unauthenticated route right or you have to bypass authentication
um so that's a you know if you've defined your goal in advance hey what i want is unauthenticated rce
then you can start from there if you are a bug bounty hunter and you're just looking to cash in
maybe you can you know get bugs uh get rewards for post-auth xss or something like that right
um so it's just it's helpful to know in your head what am i going for here um and have that well
defined from the beginning okay so next i kind of wanted to throw a little theory out there before
we jump into everything i've been sitting here looking at all the vulnerabilities that sort of
powered this episode and um all the articles and stuff like that and i think i think that there are really
three areas that almost all of the vulnerabilities that we find sort of sort of uh come together sort
of narrow down to when you think about it the first one is tracing the data flow better than the
developer the second one is knowing the nuances of the context where your payload is landing better than
the developer and then the third and last one is just of course the developer makes some sort of mistake
and forgets a security control so let's look at each one of those really quick and kind of talk about
those from a high level so that we can understand where all the other vulnerabilities that that um you'll
see sort of how it falls into that model and you can start thinking about it from a more abstracted perspective
okay so tracing the data flow better um this often you know this is a pretty common scenario
where the developer just doesn't understand that what they are working with at the time is user input
um i'm going to give you an example of this from a real vulnerability that i found
um we me and my buddy we uploaded a zip file and this uh it extracts and pulls a file out of that zip
and then inside of that file there's xml and inside of that xml there's an attribute okay and somewhere
down in the pipeline that attribute got embedded into a command line shell out and we were able to
escape that that command line argument and get rc via command line injection okay and that's a classic
scenario of like oh because it was so abstracted because you know they had parsed the xml the xml was
different from the file it was you know far away from the zip and you know it was it was in a job that
was not even you know correlated with that original http request i think the developer just didn't realize
that they were dealing with malicious input here okay so this is one of the things that we're going to
talk about a good bit in this in this session uh is you just really need to get super good at tracing dataflow
like i know that that is super dumb and basic to say okay but really that's the meat of it is you need
to know if data is coming in right where where is it going all the way through the pipeline right if
there's one skill that i can tell you to master it's that just tracing where the data is going to go
through all of the sources all the way to the scenes okay um second one is knowing the nuances of where
your payload is landing better than the developers um there's a really good example of this let me go
ahead and pull it up here in um one of the sl cyber write-ups i'm going to reference them a lot
um shout out to shubs and the team for also helping with this episode um i'm gonna i'm gonna share
my screen here as well so that you guys can see this this snippet uh from the um from the write-up
but essentially it says another key implementation here uh implementation detail that must be well known
by those writing any file and path operations in c sharp is how path combine works we've seen this
throughout our careers as source code auditors where the usage of path combine leads to critical
vulnerabilities if the second argument of path combine usually the user input if it is an absolute path
the previous argument is completely ignored and the absolute path is returned the documentation does
try to make this obvious be this behavior obvious clearly stating and then proceeds to quote the
documentation which says the exact same thing okay um so this is a perfect example of like hey the
developer thinks that what they're doing with path combine is pre-pending you know a uh you know
a certain path that locks the user into a directory but really you can supply an arbitrary directory and
as the second argument and it just removes the first argument right um and so that's a classic
example of like well if you understand the nuances of this technology better than the developers themselves
um then you'll be able to find vulnerabilities like path traversal or i guess it's not really even a
traversal here it's just arbitrary path injection here um another classic example of this like
understood understanding the nuances of the the payload or the the context in which your your um input
is getting injected is xxe right a lot of people don't realize when they're parsing xxe or uh part
parsing xxe man you can see in my hacker brain when they're when they're parsing xml that xml has this
crazy ability to like request files and like send http requests and stuff like that like why would why
would it have that um and the only way that you can exploit that is by knowing more about xml than the
people using the xml right um so number two here on the list is knowing the nuances of where your payload
is landing better than developers and this takes a lot of work and ai can certainly help with this
right you can you can ask it to learn about a specific technology stack or um even a specific
function how it's implemented uh right we saw that with with path um the path combine call out there
um yeah just really need to know where your path where your your input is landing in what context and we'll
talk a little bit more later about the more complex that context the better okay and then last but not
least on my list of three items is forgetting a security control okay um this one's basic there are
security controls in place in the app uh or maybe there aren't any at all and they just completely
forgot about security altogether but if somebody forgets the security control then of course you can just
boop plop in there and exploit it okay so here are the main things abstracted up as high as i can uh that
you should look for tracing the data better than than the the developers themselves realizing that you
control a piece of data deep deep deep deep deep deep in the app um knowing the nuances of where your
payload lands better than the developer right understanding the context and then looking for forgotten
security controls or like you know uh the lack of security controls in general okay so those are some
sort of abstracted stuff that i thought you guys might benefit from um i keep that under the set
your goal um heading uh because these are sort of things we need to think about as we're going into
the app okay now let's talk about getting our hands on the software um a lot of times we have open source
software and that's great we can just audit the source code directly from there and you may even
want to pick your target based off of the fact that you have access to source code i've talked on an
episode recently about hacking on sdks those are really good attack surface because you have the source
code for the sdk and you can just audit it and look for vulnerabilities in there um but if you need to
get your hands on source code and it's not open source there are a couple ways you can do it one you
got to look for docker images supplied by the organization that's a great way to do it um aws
azure or gcp images also in the cloud environment sometimes they have those set up so that you can
set up that software and get a trial or whatever moving very quickly without having to talk to a
sales team we've seen that a couple times um i figure i'll just shout this out as well you also
should look into packages and related packages um to the actual main you know app uh in pip and npm
we just saw recently with cloud code you know cloud code we can look at the minified javascript or
whatever but they shipped their map files right and uh you know if if you've got the map files that
makes your life a lot easier um so make sure you check uh the repositories um the packages the package
managers that's what i'm saying uh the package manage repos and know that those are not necessarily
going to correlate with a github repo you know there may not even be a github repo but even if there is
a github repo note that there may be something different in the package manager um there so keep that in mind
um another option is reversing it right uh we oftentimes will get a binary or something like
that and it's reversible with like dot peak or maybe if you got a jar you can convert it back to java
or whatever you got to know that what type of um language was used to create this binary and is it
possible for me to reverse stuff out um another shout lately is that we've been using ghidra with a very
very very very dense binary um and just hooking claude into it via mcp it's cracked guys it's freaking
cracked and i've actually seen a couple people on twitter being like uh what the heck my job is gone
you know like like really really good um reverse engineers just kind of saying sadly like man this is
my art i've been like working on this art for a long time and now claude can just come in there and just
be like hmm it goes like this and then it goes you know and so um even if you're not good at reverse
engineering hook clawed up to ghidra and you're gonna get some crazy results out of that okay um
and then here was another shout that i you know i i'll have to look up the source for this where this
came out came from because i didn't see it in one of the articles it was actually from the notes of our
researcher um but he's he noted down pay somebody to set up a server with this on it on fiverr or
freelancer.com right like even if it's a couple hundred bucks like hit up a developer that works with
this software stack and just says hey uh can you just like put this on the server and set it up
and then you've got it set up and that's the best 200 bucks you've ever spent spending your life if you
know how much of a pain it is to get stuff set up um and then you can jump on that that um server
reverse you know grab the code out and apply some of the other techniques that we just mentioned
um but yeah once you've got your hands on the code then we go to the next step um which is you
you really do need to set up the code and get a local environment um guys this is where ai is really
super game-changing okay ai knows how to set stuff up better than anything i've ever seen in my life
dude and if there's one area where i save a lot of time it is this like where i just wouldn't bother
with it before because it's like oh my gosh this is so excruciatingly painful to set stuff up
like i just can't do it right if there's not a docker image you can just throw ai at it and ai will
turn turn turn turn turn turn until it gets it working um such a big big win to use quad for this
sort of thing um and then as much as i have been on the fence about it hooking a debugger into this
stuff is really really legendary guys um i've played with it a little bit lately and i have to say like
i i used to be a proponent for just like try to eat it at the main server you know
look at the source code try to figure it out it's so unbelievably overpowered to set a you know a debug
breakpoint and then just be able to see and inspect live um variables so if you're if you're going to
sit down and you're going to be serious about it if you're going to reverse some code get it spun up
attach debugger and you're good to go this is another area where um ai can really really help a ton
okay so we're we're through the boring stuff here figure out a way to get your hands on the source
code and get that set up and get a debugger hooked into it okay all right next mapping the software
okay um this is an essential first step a lot of people say okay we we prefer sync based analysis if
you listen to some of the episodes back when joel was a co-host we debated a good bit like hey should we
start at syncs should we start at sources what's the idea here um whatever the idea is you should
map the software first okay and i personally think that moving from a source enumeration perspective
at the beginning really gives you a a strong understanding of the app um but either way you
need to understand the basic structure of the app before you you start going in and trying to find
you know the exec function or something like that where that you want to map up to a source okay
um and once again ai comes in super clutch here it can build you graphs it can lay you know slurp up
the build files which is one of the things i wanted to recommend is taking a look at the actual build
files and um and looking at the various services that they're sort of you know duct taping together in
some of these enterprise apps um but it can look at all that stuff and it can create a map for you of
what the application looks like and guys that is so valuable okay um one of the things i've learned by
working really closely with chubs a couple times is how much impact he gets out of finding weird little
apis that were hidden in a corner that aren't defined the same way that have some exception that are
routed a little bit differently and uh you know he turns that into magic time and time again okay so
if you know maybe your app is just vanilla and it's just normal you know python flask routes in
a file you know but you got to make freaking sure that that's the case okay and that there's not any
other microservice or um web socket server or like grpc something something you know that's like hiding in
a corner uh that you can go after okay so that's something you really have to pay attention to i
noted i noted just a second ago um that we should be talking about um you know these route definitions
and the routing well reverse proxy is another big piece here are they using that reverse proxy to wall
off certain endpoints or certain parts of the the routing on the back end right don't just look at
the router and assume that all that stuff is accessible and then you know when you hit your
your uh you know production server you're like oh that route isn't accessible blah blah blah you've got
to look at the reverse proxy that's the first layer right and understand what they're trying to wall off
and that also can give you a nice treasure map for what you should get access to okay reverse proxy
configuration is very important middleware configurations equally as important okay a lot
of times auth is being applied at the middleware level so figure out what decorator or um you know
additional piece that gets built into these routes is applying the auth middleware and check that it is
holistically applied across all the routes if it's not that could be a good gadget okay um so make sure
you're checking all those you're looking for web sockets you're looking for grpc you're looking at
the reverse proxies you're looking at the routes definitions and don't skip the boring parts of all
of this okay the grafana ssrf that i found in 2020 which is one that i refer to all the time because
it's such a classic example of a a clean exploit okay um this exploit was found in the avatars route for for
grafana okay this is the grafana ssrf um and it would hit gravatar on the on the on the back end and
then uh i got a redirect off of gravatar to aws metadata credentials okay and if i had if i had skipped
the avatar route on grafana then i would not have found that and the avatar route is not typically the
most interesting path right um but we really need to be thorough about it and it was an unauthenticated path
which is what drew me to it in the first place um so make sure you're being thorough and not skipping
any of those boring boring quote unquote boring looking paths okay you know what's going to be
boring is when you don't submit any dang reports because you didn't look at the boring routes
um so yeah i mentioned that you should look for services that are explicitly not exposed by the
reverse proxy um i also wanted to mention here that you can use stuff like assets no asset notes or sl cybers
uh excuse me uh hyoketsu which is uh h-y-o-k-e-t-s-u that's japanese for verdict hyoketsu um and
what that does is it scans the it supports various um uh source code um bases uh but for example it'll look for
jars that are known uh open source libraries or um reused code right and then you can not spend
your time decompiling all those and trying to cross correlate them um so this is a great way to like
get out all the fluff and look at the meat of what is the custom code from this application
um so then you're not spending a bunch of time searching for you know zero days in some apache jar
file right um that being said i also had in my notes here that sometimes when the single point of
failure might be a third-party library sometimes it it it's worth it to to look into that a little
bit okay um and it depends on what program you're working with you know if you're if you're trying
to if they're really not going to pay for third-party bugs if you're doing this from a bug bounty
perspective um you know then obviously you need to not do that on the other hand right um but i do
often find that if they're using some rinky-dink little like you know 200 star on github library
there's a decent chance that there actually might be a problem with that so that could be another area
where we could see some tooling get introduced soon is like um uh sl cyber hyoketsu um sort of i just
wanted to go off in japanese there uh like the hyoketsu something that looks like hyoketsu uh but for
identifying open source libraries or um you know reused code that is very low star on github or on the
package managers or whatever right um that could be another really interesting attack surface to go after
if they're using a a not very popular dependency um just a thought um once again just sort of jumping
into the ai for this specific section um really this we you really want to be using ai for mapping this
out this is one of the biggest productivity gains you gain with ai right now is i feel like i can ingest a
code base in like freaking 30 minutes now whereas it would take four or five six hours sometimes before
to like understand okay this is here this is there you know and i feel like i have a good good grasp of
it 30 minutes in um very very helpful massive productivity gains okay so we've covered um you know
set your goal set up the software um get your hands on the software that sort of thing um map the software
and now we're going to go into now we understand the architecture we understand the attack surface
and we're going to start doing the actual assessment okay um i i always kind of call this segment
um this portion sniffing for blood because there are just so many how do i put this there are so many
signs there's so many like um patterns that will just give you a sketchy feeling if you've done this for a
little while and even if you haven't done this for a little while if you've read a lot of write-ups
you'll look at something and you'll be like that's a little weird right um and i was trying to figure
out how to abstract that up and the only way that i think i can describe it is when our user input and
like enters a more complex environment okay that's i think that's really the root of it is our our you know
if our string input that comes from a query parameter or something like that is just compared to a string
right you know it's not that complex there's not a lot of wiggle room there right it's not probably
setting off your alarm sensors for like um you know this could be vulnerable if instead our query parameter
is put into a configuration file that can controls you know has a whole language in this configuration file that's at our disposal
then you know the gears are turning a little bit here where you're like wow
my simple user input just ended up in a really complex environment same thing we see with xss right
you know one one of the ones i love to point to is if our input is inputted inside of a string inside of a
script tag inside of html right there's just so many layers of complexity there right how is that string used
we've got string um features we can use with like backslash unicode escapes we've got um hexadecimal
definitions uh you've got so many different things and then you've got the script layer okay now we're in
javascript you know what can i do here let me break out with a single quote um okay we're in html i i
got to make sure that those you know angle brackets and the slash are escaped even if the single and
double quotes are because i can just cut off the tag right there's just so many layers of complexity
um when our user input ends up in various contexts and as that complexity continues to increase that's where
things get sketchy okay so that's the one of the more high high level principles that i would like to
convey to you is look for your input entering complex environments what are some complex environments
well let's talk through some of those okay i created a little list here um of course we have
the traditional ones like um database strings right like sql injection um why is that complex there's
various encodings we can use there's there's um you know inside of the sql or database string right there
is a syntax there double quotes single quotes or strings you know that sort of thing that's an
increasing complexity and comes along with massive capability right if it gets if it just gets complex
that's great but we also have to be able to do something right if we can break out of our string
in a database we can query the database right to the database sometimes execute commands right
complexity plus capability very important some other areas where we might see that complexity
i mentioned config files from before i think configuration file injection is a super underrated
vulnerability type there's different language syntax there's encodings there's there's uh you
know some of these languages you can just like javascript or um you know inside of the javascript
screen you can write in escaped hex right um there's all sorts of stuff unicode right so definitely
configuration file injection um if our user input ends up in a url we've got traversals we've got the
various parts of the url that we can um create segments for with question mark pops us into the query
uh hashtag pops us into the hash right if we're defining the the domain portion the at sign pops
us into the username and password field right there these areas where there are different grammars in
place that's where we need to be you know living and it takes an understanding of the technology that
you're working with right which is why that mapping and understanding the architecture of the application
and the technology base that you're working with is super important and answering some of those
core questions like okay my input just ended up here what capabilities does that have okay and that
brings it all back up to the top when i was talking to you guys in the beginning about understanding
the nuances of where your payload lands better than the developer who wrote it right that's what
we're talking about here with this complexity okay so hopefully i didn't drive that home too hard
uh here are a couple other ones that are interesting um if your input lands in an api request body not just
the path right that's also interesting can you um escape out of the json freaking franz rosen told
me to start doing this i was like dude nobody ever like doesn't use a library to parse json or create
json and then i started looking for it and i found a couple of them and i was like ate my words there so
um make sure you're looking for weird concatenation of json um xml other entities you know even some of these
binary protocols i just talked last week about um protobuf structures right binary protobuf structures
um being able to input into these very impactful sometimes we're looking at templates concatenation
with templates um and one of the ones that shubs called out as well as an increasingly complex
environment is any sort of dynamic code evaluation paths this is something that i've seen shubs do really well
um he mentioned a couple xslt rhino script uh jel um any sort of sandbox environment where you are getting
you know plopped into a sandbox uh those are really interesting to look at so your your alarm
should be going off boom boom boom boom whenever you see our input landing in dynamic code evaluation
paths or increasingly complex environments okay hope i drove that home um another thing to look for that
kind of uh leads to that that weird tingly spidey sense on where the vulnerability is is code that
seems to be interested implemented in a different way or you know a legacy way from the main code base so
once you've mapped out the architecture um you know you understand what where is the majority of the
functionality living it's living in this main api that's defined in this flask blah blah blah um but
as soon like even if there's another api completely whichever one's not the like main api is just
inherently interesting so um that's another area to look for for um for issues okay i tried to i tried to
get as much of that abstracted as possible um and i i think there are probably a lot of other areas where
where you can um sniff for blood right where you can sort of um where you get a spidey sense for where
the vulnerabilities may be but these are the ones that i came up with that i thought were most abstractable
um okay now let's talk a little bit about uh some common pitfalls and then we'll go into some patterns
that sort of extend actually you know what let's jump over to the patterns first we'll we'll jump to the
patterns and then we'll jump back to the actual things that seal the deal in some of these environments
okay so what kind of patterns do we see in addition to um our our input landing in increasingly complex
environments which often results in vulnerabilities and we pulled these from a bunch of different
research a lot of the asinode write-ups a lot of just stuff i have bookmarked on on twitter um a lot of
talks uh across youtube on source code analysis that sort of thing and we kind of put them into
like top five bullet points here um to try to show you guys what we've got so the first one that came
up is parser differentials um this is something that uh the team over at yes we hack uh has done an
excellent job of writing up recently so definitely check that out we'll link that in the description but
um there are going to be a lot of uh a lot of scenarios where parser differentials um cause
vulnerabilities and one of the most common patterns i've seen here is there being a well-defined security
layer and then there being a well-defined you know application layer and the security layer
i've noticed that if the security layer just gives you a yes no then it's it's less effective and that
isn't always the case right but one of the things i really like to do is you know look at the security
layer and and the security layer doesn't pass the input to the application layer is what i'm trying to
say so example request comes in hits the security layer the security letter says okay and then it
passes the request to the application layer right um versus the security layer saying uh here's the
information to the application layer does that make a little sense there's like a direct handoff between
the the security layer and application layer and the reason for that is um there are two preparation
processes is is what i'm calling it right now i'm sure there's a different way to um define it but
whenever you're parsing unstructured data um for example i will just give the example of a json parse
right let's say your your security layer lives in in a javascript environment and using json.parse
and yeah i'm just pulling this out of my out of my hat here um and in your back end is using python
which uses json.loads right these are two different parsing environments and there might be a differential
between those two and so the security layer can just say sure here you know this seems fine
pass it you know pass it back and say all good and then the routing layer you know sort of passes it
to the application layer on the back end versus let's say a scenario where you have something more
monolithic um a javascript security layer and and a javascript um back end and it just passes the
object directly from the security layer into the um the application layer okay does that make sense so
there's there's there's there's different preparation processes across the front end and the back end where
the security is implemented in the front i hope that makes sense there's lots of different examples of
parser differentials um across lots of different uh environments so just be on the lookout for those on
how the data is being processed um next was uh chaining okay that's another common um scenario that we see
is that a lot of times these more complex vulnerabilities especially in the enterprise
applications are not single bugs they are multiple chained bugs together and this is where i start to
think ai is going to have some problems certainly we should be using ai and really ai is great for this
right uh we can tell it hey look i've got this i've got this i've got this i actually just told it like
an hour ago look i've got this csbt i need an arbitrary json hosting primitive okay find me this
find it for me now you know and and it you know goes across everything it knows across about the code
base and it says look the most likely places for this to exist are here here here and i'm gonna work
through them one by one and it goes through it and you go through it at the same time and you're
you know handing stuff back and forth right so i would really encourage you guys as you use ai you
know one of the things it's not great at is yet is doing this multiple chain thing right so you have
to be the multiple chain thing make it document gadgets make it document things that you you know
that you've used in other pieces of in other chains right this is the importance of like maintaining a
nice cloud md file that where the the ai knows okay arbitrary json hosting for justin is a very very
valuable gadget right um and then bringing them together uh to complete the chains and and same
for um same for just forcing it to find the other piece of the chain that you need right then you
don't have to go through uh all the mental duress of like man i really need an open redirect right now
like where the heck am i supposed to find an open redirect and you kind of offload it to the ai see what it
comes out with okay so good stuff there chaining is essential to high quality um uh you know
source code auditing in my opinion okay next up is dependency auditing i sort of mentioned to the this
to you all before but if you've got a dependency that looks a little sus it might be a good idea to
take a peek at that especially if it's low stars or um the source code just looks a little different
right um i this one was one i added in myself because i've been finding vulnerabilities here
um and typically when they're in programs that value impact they pay pretty dang well um so don't sleep
on that and i wish you know i i hope all the guys like ronnie and and uh the people that do dependency
confusion vulnerabilities i hope they that that becomes a little bit more widely expect accepted
in the bounty space right now because um man it is is impactful uh if you compromise a dependency and
then boom your whole source code's gone really crazy um okay uh next one is the validate then transform
um code pattern we see this pretty often you know there's something for me the episode i mean i was
pretty far into my you know professional hacking career when i did this the dom purify episode with
kevin mizu but in that episode for me is where it became super concrete what kevin was emphasizing in
that episode was that if you do anything anything to the string after you put it through dom purify
then it is polluted and you can very very very likely you know cause a problem the the dom purify
sanitization step needs to be like pretty much wrapped in the whatever is going to write write it to
the dom um for this to actually work properly um and similarly any sort of sanitization any sort of
validation checking um that you do for vulnerabilities really needs to be right before the sink where it is
where it would potentially be abused okay i'm gonna say that again when there's some sanitization or or
checks for malicious input it needs to be right before the place where it would be maliciously used
okay if it's not any anything in that space is interesting right what happens between the check
and the actual sink um that is it one of the most common things that we see is you know code gets more
complex over time that that little segment between the validation and the sink it's bigger when somebody
adds in a little feature here or there right um so make sure you're checking that space between the
validation and the sink um another big one that i've seen often is alternative sources okay i'm going to
tell you guys a quick story about this one so i was banging my head up against an app i was like man if i could
get xss here this would be game changing because of the way of the the way the app works right unauthenticated
input it would be great um anyway it would compromise the whole app because of warmability okay so i was
banging my head up against this markdown uh editor and i'm like surely there's something here i can find
couldn't find it anyway i notice that there's also a way for me to send text messages into this application
and i'm like all right you know let me let me let me try that out so i whip out my phone i write a you
know message uh an actual uh html message on my phone and i send it and i typoed it so i send it again
and it pops on the admin panel and i'm like frick yes um so you one of the the takeaway from this being
is look for all alternate sources into the place where you want your data to to live okay um surely
there's going to be the traditional path but there's also going to be maybe legacy endpoints v1
v2 v0 endpoints right there's going to be alternate data streams is data coming in from sms is data coming
in from web sockets is data coming in from you know being loaded in by a a mass import from a
configuration file right maybe that one's missing the sanitization that's happening at the source
rather than the sink and that's why we we sanitize more at the sink rather than at the source because
like there's you know you have to hit every single source right versus if you sanitize right before
the sink then you know you know it's just going to go right into the sink does that make sense okay i i hope
it does so look for alternative sources for data to flow into the application and look for patterns
of where they're putting that sanitization if they're putting it at the source or at the sink
um yeah and and i just wanted to say you know in with regards to ai and these common patterns
you can take these patterns we'll we'll have them in the hacker notes and you can tell ai hey look for
these across the application look for sanitization that is far from the the sink look for um you know sus
dependencies look for this um you know alternative sources into the same spot look for the look for
these gadgets that i need um ai is just here to bolster all of that uh as you as you do your security
assessment okay um now let's jump into a couple common pitfalls that sort of close the deal in a lot
of situations i i ranted a little bit about this on a recent episode but freaking casing guys let me tell
you casing causes a lot of dang problems okay so just keep that in mind um uppercase letter lowercase letter
things are going to parse those things you know the same or different right um and it's good to know
which one's which unicode normalization much like uh you know the casing is also something that is uh
often causes a lot of problems that one's a little bit less easy to spot in the source code review
um that is something that you could shout to ai and be like yo you see any like unicode normalization
issues here uh where you know unicode is potentially being processed um could be a a good a good piece
once again you'll see that more in increasingly complex environments if you're handing off from
one technology stack to another technology stack what are the assumptions that are between these two
technology stacks okay that may not hold true in all edge cases um another one this is really funny
that we see really often two i'll give you non-global replacement and bad regex like they get their own
shout outs here because they are so common okay if somebody's trying to replace something they very very
often forget the uh you know the global piece or the recursive element of it right you know especially
when they're sanitizing with a replace that's just hacked okay so anytime you see a replacement on your
input just like stare at it for a couple minutes and be like hmm hmm and something will jump out to
you that's what i do i just i say replace all right i'm gonna be staring at this for the next 10 15 seconds
at least um definitely a good use of time um bad regex like i mentioned a second ago very common dot escapes
missing um you know up arrow at the beginning or dollar sign at the end super common um look look
deep into this uh because there are there are really some some things that people can miss here
um one of the ones that i really like is a backslash inside of square brackets trying to escape stuff
that you don't need to escape and accidentally putting the backslash character inside of square brackets
and thinking that it's it's uh you know it's actually backslash escaping something okay um really really
fun scenario there uh encodings another thing you know we mentioned uh unicode but you've got to
master all of your encodings of course um yeah incomplete syntax checks is another really big one
for example i mean the big one that just comes to your mind is like oh if they're just looking for like
script tag for xss input these are this i'm giving you this example i know you know this
right but let's generalize it a little bit let's abstract it a little bit to any sort of incomplete
syntax checks anytime you are looking for you know the the code is looking for a specific syntax to
disallow right that's when we need to think okay is that disallow list is that block list
really thorough or not and are there any cases can i capitalize my script tag can i you know use a svg
on event handler right um what else can i do here that will um address this incomplete block list
very common these are the kind of things that seal the deal right once you've found you submit sniff
the blood you find an unauthenticated route from the legacy api you go in there you're looking at the
code bad sanitization boom xss boom file read whatever um this is one that i added to the list
because we see it a lot with like rce write-ups which is uh you know something that we used largely for
this um uh meta-analysis here uh is dynamic function calling so by this what i mean i mean there's lots of
ways that you can do this but the one that sort of rings true for me in php because we covered it on
episode a long time ago with the word fence team is this like really weird method invocation uh structure
where you can just call a string in php right you have a string and it has a function's name in it and
you just call it right and it's like oh wow that works like that's crazy um so it's really important to
do your your data tracing there and see if there's any sort of scenario where you're essentially doing
an rpc right like a remote procedure call um because that is is where a lot of yuck comes in and a lot of
flexibility for the attacker okay um so keeping out and on an eye for any of those keep an eye out is what
i meant to say for any of those situations as i'm saying that keep an eye out is such a weird english
phrase right like keep an eye out like your eye anyway i digress um got a couple more here and then
we'll wrap uh for this episode um incomplete application like i mentioned before of security
controls that's another really big one ask the ai this is something that i can really help you with
where are the pivotal security controls here if they are not globally applied as middleware
how how do i check whether everything has this you know function call right at the beginning of
its route handler right how do i check whether um you know there are any weird places where where
this function is not being called properly or or maybe it's like in an if statement with another condition
or you know the way that this function is called seems non-standardized right like i just mentioned
the if if statement just a second ago maybe one of them is a truthy sort of thing right um that's
another big thing is truthy issues and and typing checks um we need to be there needs to be consistent
across the board right any sort of auth or um sanitization checks need to be consistently implemented
across the board and any variance is a very very common pitfall um in a an area that you should look
deeply into um another one that came up here is making auth decisions off of an inconsistent source
okay um like as i said a moment ago the middleware if it's not globally applied where where are they
getting their auth information is this coming from anywhere except this bearer or this cookie or this
one function that processes it as a part of the http request if they are um then we need to know where
that is and we need to double click into that deeply okay um so that's a really big one as well
lastly we have custom sanitizers okay um a lot of times we have things like dom purify for a reason
right there are going to be um very very complex environments where our input is landing if you see
a custom sanitizer you need to be very very locked in on that and um you may even be able to instrument
it to fuzz it a little bit better um that's something that i've done in the past um and when you do
something often falls out and it may not be a full bypass but a partial bypass sometimes can be enough
to give you another gadget in your chain which you can chain with something else um all right y'all
that's just a bunch of me ranting about stuff i i we're going to have a ton of resources linked
in the description uh from this episode that you can go to learn more about source code analysis i tried
to summarize it best i can i wanted to so really give a lot of respect to those people um whose work
is in their description i really really appreciate the write-ups that they did but i want to give a special
thanks to shubs rafax and fsi um for giving uh direct feedback or direct input into this episode
um and really changing the way that we that we thought about this um this episode from the meta
analysis perspective so shout out to them um and i hope you guys gain some value out of that keep
hacking y'all keep popping bugs and zero days on these uh on these code bases all right all right peace
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there